how often do your dear sex sexual
sessions last let me tell you something
I have one partner seven minutes that's
why I try to tell people seven minutes
is enough but I think that seven times
five and every time you move to the next
it's gonna last longer than seven
minutes isn't it
you can't possibly come five times a day
the next say what did the text say that
you sent the other Demi's obviously
there's some text about jism the other
day thinking what text about design
we're out of mops again yeah you can
really come five times a day at least
Jesus Christ I'm good for one yeah me
too one one really good one one yeah I
was like that when I was married to one
woman and then you realize with what the
body is capable of that's when things go
wrong if I'm not going to entertain all
of them that's when trouble stuff
yeah it becomes new again if there's
somebody new it's a whole new experience
it's inspiring you know for a man it's
it's motivating right to do right you
see this other and you're like yeah yeah
yeah I can do it I can do and you set go
cuz you're an athlete at heart
yeah you set goals for performance yeah
you want to be the best i trough a
training I've been training twice a day
every day you're putting in five days
now